no one starts us off in Tucson Arizona
hi Devon how are you yeah are you know
better than I deserve what's up I was
calling about trying to figure out if I
should attempted to sell my house and
right now I'm currently on half the
equity in it due to some life situations
back a few years ago I ended up trying
to help out family and we ended up I
ended up at helping my dad buy half a
house it was my Nana's house after she
died or before she died and then I
bought it afterwards so who let your dad
owns the other half now I'm sorry what
who owns the other half today my father
okay who lives in the house I do and
then my brother and my girlfriend okay
and does your dad want the house I'm
from my understanding he's one thing
he's not wanting to sell it yet but I
haven't really sat down talked to him a
lot about it I've tried it I'm trying to
get through the holiday season first
before we kick up any big waves you know
okay so you think this was going to be a
big wave then okay yeah I kind of yeah I
can see it being that so they're sure
you're ready in there who's making the
payment you yeah and because he's
already paid for his house because he
inherited a third of it and then he
ended up pan off the rest with cash Oh
mostly and so the only mortgage on that
your mortgage it might have yeah okay
and how much do you have on it I have a
fifty one thousand five hundred okay and
what do you make a year I make a
forty-two thousand ear in what situation
would you keep it and why would you sell
it um right now I'm not sure exactly
what just me having a house would be
nice you know and having my kids grow up
and so actually I don't have any kids
right now but having kids grow up in the
house where we had generation that would
be really cool
living in the house but then also at the
same time you know trying to figure out
if I want to get serious with my
girlfriend she's we've been together for
like three and a half years and we're
trying to figure out if we want to take
a relationship another step but it's
kind of hard to do that when you have an
extra body in the house and can you just
evict him yeah we can't really just
because that's sort of the the deal my
dad dad says he's living there for em
for free yeah forget he's a hunter my
dad pretty much that's sort of the deal
with that honestly okay and well dad in
order for okay so it sounds something
like this in order for you to have a
high-quality future
this partnership needs to be undone and
so you need to either buy your dad out
or the house needs to be sold because
you can't live there with your future
wife and have just this strange other
human that happens to be your brother
living there because you did a bad deal
that's just weird okay family dynamic
wise it's weird is what you're saying
and I'm agreeing I'm agreeing with you
okay and yeah you really can't move him
out I get it your dad owns half of it
his half he gives to your brother to use
and so you know but if he wanted to give
it to three donations he could yeah you
know I mean it just leaves you in a
pinch is in a pickle is the problem and
that you know so I dad that we've got to
develop a game plan and we want to do it
instantaneously but over the next 12 to
24 months I've got to have a better game
plan and then neither involves me buying
you out you buying me out or we sell the
house because I'm not going to live with
my brother when I'm 60 yeah this has not
the list doesn't scale it's not got good
long-term planning to it and it didn't
from the start you guys treated it you
guys came up with a real good short-term
solution and no long-term plan and
that's why what happened yeah that's why
you're in a mess because the house came
up for sale and you're like oh I got to
jump in to save the house and yeah I'd
be cool to be there for generations but
it wouldn't be cool to be there for
generations and your brother living with
you for years after you're married you
five kids I mean that's just weird that
you're forced into it I mean if you just
chose to do it that's fine but just just
being forced into it by the situation is
just weird so now I agree with you I
think something needs to change in the
deal and so after the holidays it's time
to make some waves and it's like guys
I'm not mad at anybody it's just five
years from now this doesn't work for me
and so I got to start working on a
five-year plan which involves me getting
married and involves me owning home and
by the way your girlfriend for sure when
she becomes your wife ain't no like
living with our brother-in-law because
our father-in-law said so that's going
to really get weird in your relationship
with her just warning you that's not
going to go well this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]